I accidentally laminated my brows too
much
Selena Gomez and Kylie Jenner band
together to shut down claims that Kylie
teamed up with Haley Bieber to bully
Selena and it's all about eyebrows I was
okay with dealing with it yeah let's
let's rewind
earlier this week Selena shared this
clip on Tick Tock referencing her newly
done brows I accidentally laminated my
brows too much shortly after that Kylie
posted this snap writing this was an
accident over her brows before sharing a
close-up pic of Haley's brows well
that's when the internet did what the
internet does with many claiming Kylie
and Haley were throwing shade at cell I
also feel like kind of like awkward
about it in fact the whole eyebrow
debacle had people talking so much that
Haley's name started trending on Twitter
yeah that's me that's when Kylie slid
into the comments of a Fan's Tick Tock
about the supposed drama to slam the
suggestion that her post was about
Selena this is reaching no shade towards
Selena ever and I didn't see her eyebrow
posts you guys are making something out
of nothing this is silly so crazy Selena
then responded directly to Kylie's
comment writing agreed Kylie Jenner it's
all unnecessary I'm a fan of Kylie yes
it's finally done this is the second
time in the last few weeks that fans
have tried to spark drama between Haley
and Selena after some accused Haley and
Kendall Jenner of body shaming Selena in
a since deleted Tick Tock and I'm not
saying she does
God's day
when one tick tocker posted about the
theory Selena hopped into the comments
with it's okay I don't let these things
get me down be nice to everyone
[Music]
of course back in September Selena and
Haley broke the internet squashing
rumors that there's beef between them
after Haley opened up on call her daddy
about all the bullying she's faced from
fans of both her husband Justin Bieber
and Selena his ex over allegations that
she came between them a lot of the hate
and the perpetuation comes from like oh
you stole him it's not my character
to
mess with someone's relationship I would
just never do that I was raised better
than that shortly after that the only
murders in the building star addressed
the hate she was seeing online calling
it vile and disgusting words matter
truly matter
so
it ain't coming from me and a few weeks
later the two posted up together for
this snap hugging and getting cozy at
the Academy Museum Gala in La it means
something to me at the time A source
told E.T that the two wanted to show the
world that there's no beef or bad
feelings between them anymore I'm in a
really happy place it's been good quote
they both moved on and are happy in
their own lives
foreign